pacific and sundays at nine
next frank mccourt reads from his
best-selling memoir angela's ashes
it's the story of his birth in brooklyn
to irish immigrants his return to
ireland and his unhappy childhood in the
slums of limerick
frank mccourt spoke recently at the
library limited a st louis bookstore
ladies and gentlemen i'd like to welcome
you to library limited this evening
we're pleased to welcome frank mccourt
he is the author of the new book angelus
ashes which is doing extremely well now
it's been written up in the times twice
in the last three weeks i think
the book is his memoir of his his
childhood in ireland until the time he
was 19.
um he was also a creative writing
teacher at steinson high school in new
york city for a very long time we'd like
to welcome him was there i was there
i think that but but occasions like this
i think you're required to read a few
passages to give you a taste of what the
book is like and
or to give you the
the the music of the language
in my own voice
this book i called it angela's ashes
because i didn't know what else to call
it uh it i intended it to go on much
farther till the time my mother died in
new york in 1981 in lenox hill hospital
and
if i had done that it would be a five
foot shelf of a book so i stopped my
editor to it at
scrimmer nan graham thought it would be
good idea to just come back to america
kind of a circular motion like
finnegan's wake and books like that
to arrive in america and stop there and
then
leave you asking for more that's if
you're asking for more and if you are
you're going to get it
this is the i'm just going to read the
offering passage which in in in the
movie business is called an establishing
shot
about limerick
my father and mother should have stayed
in new york where they've met and
married and where i was born
instead they returned to ireland when i
was four my brother maliki iii the twins
oliver and eugene barely won and my
sister margaret dead and gone
when i look back at my childhood i
wonder how i survived it all it was of
course a miserable childhood
happy childhood is hardly worth your
while
worse than the ordinary miserable
childhood is the miserable irish
childhood and worse yet is the miserable
irish catholic childhood
people everywhere brag and whimper about
the woes of their early years but
nothing
can compare with the irish version
the poverty the shiftless loquacious
alcoholic father the pious defeated
mother moaning by the fire pompous
priests bullying schoolmasters the
english and the terrible things they did
to us for 800 long years
above all we were wet
out in the atlantic ocean great sheets
of rain gathered to drift slowly up the
river shannon settled forever in
limerick
the rain dampened the city from the
feast of the circumcision to new year's
eve it created a cacophony of hacking
coughs bronchial rattlers asthmatic
wheezes consumptive croaks it turn noses
into fountains lungs into bacterial
sponges it provoke cures galore to ease
the qatar you boil onions in milk
blackened with pepper for the congested
passages you made a paste of boiled
flour and nettles wrapped it in a rag
and slapped it sizzling on the chest
from october to april the walls of
limerick glistened with the damp
clothes never dried tweed and woolen
coats house living things
sometimes sprouted mysterious
vegetations in pubs steam rose from damp
bodies and garments to be in here with
cigarette and pipe smoke
laced with the stereo fumes of a spilled
stout and whiskey and tinged with the
order of piss
wafting from the outdoor jakes where
many a man puked up his week's wages
the rain drove us into the church our
refuge our strength our only dry place
at mass benediction novenas we huddled
in great damp clumps
dozing through priest drone
while steam rose again from our clothes
to mingle with the sweetness of incense
flowers and candles
limerick gained a reputation for piety
but we knew it was only the rain
much of the book deals with my father
uh well we had a unique arrangement in
our family because my father was from
the north of ireland
and they're different
from the rest of ireland
at the core at the moment and then they
were under british rule and that makes
people different
and the british are still there they
won't go home
we've invited them to go home we've told
them what benjamin franklin said that
fish and visitors stink in three days
but they won't go they're leaving hong
kong but they won't leave ireland so my
my mother from the south of ireland
which is a more well like all southern
places more an easier place
uh she didn't have the
work i was about to say she didn't have
the work ethic neither did he
he had a problem with the drink
and when he did get a job it went like
this
when ma when dad gets a job ma'am is
cheerful and she sings
anyone can see why i wanted your kiss it
had to be and the reason is this
could it be true
someone like you could love me
love me
when dad brings home the first week's
wages ma'am is delighted she can pay the
lovely italian men in the grocery shop
and she can hold her head up again
because there's nothing worse in the
world than to own to be beholden to
anyone she cleans the kitchen washes the
mugs and plates brushes crumbs and bits
of food from the table cleans out the
ice box and orders a fresh block of ice
from another italian
she buys toilet paper that we can take
down the hall to the lavatory and that
she says is better than having headlines
from the daily news blackening your ass
she boils water on the stove and spends
the day at a great tin tub washing our
shirts and socks diapers for the twins
or two sheets or three towels she hangs
everything out in the clothesline behind
the apartment house and we can watch the
clothes dance in wind and sun she says
you wouldn't want the neighbors to know
what you have in the way of a wash but
there's nothing like the sweetness of
clothes dried by the sun
when dad brings home the first week's
wages on a friday night we know the
weekend will be wonderful but saturday
night man will boil water on the stove
and wash us in the great tin tub and dad
will dry us
maliki will turn around and show he's
behind dad will pretend to be shocked
and we'll all laugh
that man will make hot cocoa and we'll
be able to stay up while dad tells us a
story out of his head all we have to do
is to say her name mr mcadore or mr
lieber which down the hall and dad would
have the two of them rolling up a river
in brazil chased by indians with green
noses and pew shoulders on night snack
that we can drift off to sleep knowing
there would be a breakfast of eggs fried
tomatoes fried bread tea with lashes of
sugar and milk and live in the day a big
dinner of mashed potatoes peas and ham
and a trifle
and the trifle man makes layers of fruit
and warm delicious custard on a cake
soaked in sherry
when dad brings home the first week's
wages and the weather is fine man takes
us to the playground she sits on a bench
and talks to minnie mcadore she tells
many stories about characters in
limerick and minnie tells her about
characters in belfast
and they laugh because there are funny
people in ireland north and south
then they
teach each other sad songs and maliki
and i leave the swings and seesaws to
sit with them on the bench and sing
a group of young soldiers one night in
the camp were talking of sweethearts
they had
all seemed so merry except one young lad
and he was down-hearted and sad
come and join us said one of the boys
surely there's someone for you
but ned shook his head and proudly he
said i am in love with two
each like a mother to me from neither of
them shall i part for one is my mother
god bless her i love her the other is my
sweet heart
malik and i sing that song and ma'am and
minnie laugh till they cry at the way
maliki takes a deep bow and holds his
arms out to ma'am at the end
dan mcadory comes along his way home
from work and says rudy valley better
start worrying about the competition
when we go home ma'am makes tea and
bread
and jam or mashed potatoes with butter
and salt dad drinks the tea and eats
nothing mom says god above how can you
work all day naheed he says the tea is
enough she says you'll ruin your health
and he tells again that food is a shock
to the system
he drinks his tea and tells us stories
and shows us letters and words in the
daily news or he smokes a cigarette
stares at the wall runs his tongue over
his lips
when dad's dad's job goes into the third
week he does not bring home the wages on
friday night we wait for him and mom
gives us bread and tea the darkness
comes down the lights come along come on
along classen avenue other men with jobs
at home already and having eggs for
dinner because you can't have meat in a
friday you can hear the families talking
upstairs and downstairs and down the
hall and bing crosby singing on the red
on the radio brother can you spare a
dime
maliki and i play with the twins we know
ma'am one thing anyone can see why i
wanted your kiss she sits at the table
talking to herself what am i going to do
till it's late and dad rolls up the
stairs singing rodney mccauley he pushes
in the door and calls for us where are
my troops where are my four warriors
ma'am says leave these boys alone
they've gone to bed half hungry because
you have to fill your belly with whiskey
he comes to the bedroom door up boys up
a nickel for everyone who promises to
die for ireland
up boys up francis maliki all over
eugene the red branch nice the fenian
men the ira up up
mamma's at the kitchen table shaking her
head her hair hanging damp her face wet
can't you leave them alone she says
jesus mary and joseph isn't it enough
you come home without a penny in your
pocket without making foods of the
children on top of it
she comes to us go back to bed she says
i want them up he says i want them ready
for the day ireland will be free from
the center to the sea
don't cross me she says for if you do
it'll be a sorry day in your mother's
house
he puts his cap down over his face and
cries my poor mother poor ireland ah
what have we got to do
ma'am says you're pure stone mad and she
tells us again to go to bed
on the morning of the fourth friday of
dad's job ma'am asks him if he'd be home
tonight with his wages or will he drink
everything again he looks at us and
shakes his head it ekman as if to say oh
you shouldn't talk like that in front of
the children
ma'am keeps at him i'm asking you are
you coming home so that we have a bitter
supper or will it be midnight with no
money in your pocket and you singing
kevin barry in the rest of the sad songs
he puts on his cap shoves his hands into
his charles's pocket sighs and looks up
to the ceiling i told you before i'll be
home he says
and of course
that he doesn't come home that night and
that was one of the big problems in our
family because
he would get a job
and using the third or fourth week
he'd go out on the friday night when
they paid and he wouldn't come home and
my mother you said this is when we were
small we lived in brooklyn
until i was four and she would put the
twins in the pram and the baby carriage
and take maliki and me along with her
and we'd go to whatever factory he
worked in in brooklyn and wait for the
men to come out at five o'clock to see
if we could catch him on the way out but
he was very clever he always found
another gate so he went off and then
we'd have to go around to the the bars
along around the long island railroad
station in brooklyn there were a whole
series of irish bars
and she'd go in and she'd send me in is
my father here he's my father here so
this and then of course we wouldn't find
and then it was a long a long uh
walk back to um
the house in classen avenue
so he had the disease of alcoholism
and he um
he he mystified me
i had a when we went back to ireland
when i was four
he got dad gets his first job in
limerick at the cement factory and ma'am
is happy she won't have to stand in the
queue at the saint vincent depart
society asking for clothes and boots for
maliki and me
she says it's not begging it's charity
but that's it it's begging and is
shameful
ma'am says she can now pay off the few
pounds she owes a kathleen o'connors and
she can pay back what she owes her own
mother she hates to be under obligation
to anyone especially her own mother
the cement factory is mild outside
limerick and that means dad has to be
out of the house by six in the morning
he doesn't mind because he's used to the
long walks the night before she makes
him a flask of tea a sandwich a
hard-boiled egg she feels sorry for him
the way he has to walk three miles out
and three miles back
a bicycle would be handy but you'd have
to be water for a year for the price of
it
friday's payday
mom is out of bed early cleaning the
house and singing anyone can see why i
wanted your kiss it had to be and the
reason is this
there isn't much to clean in our house
she sweeps the kitchen floor and the
floor of italy upstairs she washes the
four gem jars we use for mugs she says
if dad's job last we'll get proper cups
and maybe sausage and someday with the
help of gardener's best of mother we'll
have sheets on the bed and if we save a
long time a blanket or two instead of
those old coats which people must have
left behind during the great famine
she boils water and washes their eggs to
keep michael from [ __ ] all over the
pram and the house itself all she says
will have a lovely tea when your pup
brings home the wages tonight
pop she says that means she's in a good
mood
sirens and whistles go off all over the
city when the men finish work at half
past five maliki and i are excited
because we know that when your father
works and brings home the wages you get
the friday penny
we know this from other boys whose
father's work and we know that after
your tea you can go to kathleen
o'connor's shop and buy sweets if your
mother's in a good mood she might even
give you a toughest to go to the lyric
cinema the next day to see a film with
james cagney
the men who work in factories and shops
in the city are coming into the lanes to
have the supper wash themselves and go
to the pub
the women go to the films at the
coliseum with the lyric cinema they buy
sweets of wild wood buying cigarettes
and if their husbands have worked a long
time they treat themselves to boxes of
black magic chocolates
they love the romance films and they
have a great time crying their eyes out
when there's an unhappy ending or a
handsome lover goes away to be shocked
by hindus and other non-catholics
we have to wait a long time for dad to
walk the miles from the cement factory
we can't have our teeth home and that's
very hard because you smell the cooking
of other families in the lane mam says
it's a good thing payday is friday when
you can't eat meat because the smell of
bacon or sausages in other houses with
the right driver out of our mind
we could still have bread and cheese and
a nice jam jar of tea with lashes of
milk and sugar and what more do you want
the women are gone to the cinemas the
men are in the pubs
and still dad isn't home ma'am says it's
a long time to the
long way to the cement factory even if
he is a fast walker she says that but
her eyes are watery and she's not
singing anymore she's sitting by the
fire smoking a wild wood while she got
him credit from kathleen o'connell the
[ __ ] is the only luxury she has and
she'll never forget kathleen for her
goodness she doesn't know how long she
can keep the water boiling in the kettle
there's no use making the tea till dad
gets home because it will be stewed
cuddled boiled and unfit to drink
maliki says he's hungry and she gives
him a piece of bread and cheese to keep
him going she says this job could be the
saving of us it's hard enough for him to
get a job with his northern accent and
if he loses this one i don't know what
we're going to do does he come home no
that was our life then the war came
well the second world war was uh for us
a blessing
most of think people think of their
second world war as an awful disaster
but you don't know what it was like in
ireland when it gave the men an
opportunity to go off to england and
work in the factories and to join the
british army and win the war for the
british it's not generally known that
the irish won the war peace sometimes
people think it was american
intervention intervention intervention
but with unemployed irishmen
uh fighting it was always thus uh how do
you think england conquered half the
world or more or most of the world why
do you think the sun never set on the
british empire because of the irish
we conquered africa and australia
won the first world war in the second
world war so
money was coming back
and uh
people used to say what's very sad how
the germans are bombing england and so
on people men and i mean women and
children are dying over there but look
what the english did to us for 800 long
years this is all we heard
so uh
the uh the money was coming back and
families around us were beginning to
look rich
they had electric light
they would get we had no electric light
in the lane
so now the men were sending back the
money
one by one the houses got electric life
all the houses except them of course
we're still waiting for my father to
send the money we still had the candle
and one way we had of amusing ourselves
was when we went home
play acting
we acted we made plays about everything
we'd go home and our house was dark and
bleak all the other houses are blazing
with light we'd go in the door and we'd
say
switch on the light maliki
and he'd pretend to switch on the light
we'd all fall on the floor laughing at
the very idea of having electricity
but we thought we'd have it someday
then
time passes and um we're in ireland and
uh
my mother gets after my first communion
which was a disastrous day for me
my confirmation there was a disastrous
day for me
the two times i got married with
disastrous days for me
i think my funeral is going to be
disaster too
so uh in other words i have an uneasy
time with the church and its sacraments
which i'll get to in a minute but my
mother
got an idea one time that we should be
respectable
so she decided she made a decision
on a saturday morning ma'am finishes her
tea and says you're going to dance
dance why
you're seven years old you made your
first communion and now it's just time
for the dancing
i'm taking you down to kathmandu street
to mrs o'connor's irish dancing classes
you'll go there every saturday morning
that'll keep you off the streets that'll
keep you from wandering around limerick
with the hooligans
she tells me wash my face not forgetting
ears and neck comb my hair blow my nails
take that look off my face what look
never mind just take it off put on my
stockings and my first communion shoes
which she says are destroyed because i
can't pass a canister or a rock without
kicking it she's worn out standing in
the queue at the center depart society
begging for boots for me and maliki so
that we can wear our toes with the
kicking your father says it's never too
early to learn the songs and dances of
your ancestors what's ancestors never
mind
you're going to dance
i wonder
i wonder how i can die for ireland if i
have to sing and dance for ireland too i
wonder why they never say oh you can eat
sweets and stay home from school and go
swimming for ireland
ma'am says don't get smarter i'll warm
your ear
sarah benson dances
he has medals hanging from his shoulders
to his kneecaps he wins contests all
over ireland and he looks lovely and
he's suffering kills he's a credit to
his mother and he gets his name and the
paper all the time and you can be sure
he brings home the odd few pounds you
don't see him roaming the streets
kicking everything inside till the toes
hang out of his boats all know he's a
good boy dancing for his poor mother
man wits an old towel and scrubs my face
till it stings she wraps the towel
around her finger and sticks it in my
ears and claims there's enough wax there
to grow potatoes
she wets my hair to make it lie down she
tells me shut up and stop the whinging
that these dancing lessons will cost her
six months every saturday which i could
have earned bringing guild bill galvin
his dinner and god knows she can barely
afford it i tried to tell her ma'am sure
you don't have to send me to dancing
school when you could be smoking a nice
wood wearing cigarette and having a cup
of tea but she says oh you're very
clever aren't you you're going to dance
if i have to give up the [ __ ] forever
if my path see me dragging through see
my mother dragging me through the
streets to irish dancing class i'd be
disgraced entirely
they think it's all right to dance and
pretend you're fred is there because you
can jump all over the screen with ginger
rogers there's no ginger rogers in irish
dancing and you can't jump all over you
can stand straight up you stand straight
up and down and keep your arms against
yourself and kick your legs up and
around and never never smile my uncle
pack hating said irish dancers look like
they have steel rods up their asses
but i can't say that to ma'am she'd kill
me
there's a gramophone where mrs
o'connor's playing an irish jig or a
reel and boys and girls are dancing
around kicking their legs out and
keeping their hands to their sides mrs
o'connor is a great fat woman and when
she stops the record to show the steps
all the fat from her chin to her ankles
jiggles and i wonder how she can teach
the dancing she comes over to my mother
and says so this is little frankie i
think we have the makings of a dancer
here boys and girls do we have the
makings of a dancer here we do mrs
o'connor
ma'am says i have the sixth mrs o'connor
ah yes mrs mccord hold on a minute
she waddles to a table and brings over
the head of a black boy with kinky hair
big eyes huge red lips and an open mouth
she tells me put the sixpence in the
mouth and take my hand out before the
black boy bites me
all the boys and girls watch and they
have little smiles i drop in the
sixpence and pull my hand back before
the mouth snaps shut
everyone laughs and i know they wanted
to see my hand caught in the mouth
mrs o'connor gasps and laughs and says
to my mother isn't that a howl mrs
ma'am says it's a howl she tells me
behave myself and come home dancing
i don't want to stay in this place where
mrs o'connor can't take the sixpence
herself instead of letting me nearly
lose my hand in the black boy's mouth i
don't want to stay in this place where
you have to stand in line with boys and
girls straighten your back hands by your
side look ahead don't look down move
your feet move your feet look at cyril
look at cell and there goes several all
dressed up and he's suffering killed and
the medals jingling medals for this and
medals for that and the girls love cyril
and mrs o'connell loves her for didn't
he bring her fame and didn't she teach
him every step he knows oh dancer dance
oh jesus he floats around the room he's
an angel out of heaven and stop the
frowning frankie mccord or you'll have a
puss on you like a pounder tribe dance
frankie dance pick up your feet for the
love of jesus one two three four five
six seven one two three and one two
three mara will you help that frankie
mccord before he ties his two feet
around his head entirely help him maura
mar is a big girl about 10. she dances
up to me with her white teeth and her
dancer's dress with all the gold and
yellow and green figures that are
supposed to come from olden times and
she says give me your hand little boy
and she wheels me around the room till
i'm dizzy and making a pure egypt of
myself
and blushing and foolish till i want to
cry but i'm saved when the record stops
and the grammar from goes
mrs o'connor says oh thank you maura and
next week sarah you can show frankie a
few of the steps that made you famous
next week boys and girls and don't
forget the six months for the little
black boy
boys and girls leave together i make my
own way down the stairs out the door
hoping my pals won't see me with boys
who wear kilts and girls with white
teeth and fancy dresses from olden times
ma'am is having tea with brighty hennan
her friend from next door ma'am says
what did you learn it makes me dance
around the kitchen one two three four
five six seven one two three and one two
three she has a good laugh with brighty
that's not too bad for your first time
in the month you'll be a regular cyril
benson i don't want to be sarah benson i
want to be afraid of stare they turn
hysterical laughing and squirting tea
out of their mouths jesus love him says
brady doesn't he have a great notion of
himself fred is there how are you
ma'am says fred astaire went to his
lessons every saturday and didn't go
around kicking the tools out of his
boats and if i wanted to be like him i'd
have to go to mrs o'connor's every
single week the fourth side of the
morning billy campbell knocks at our
door mrs mccoy can frankie come out and
play
ma'am tells him no billy frankie is
going to his dancing lessons
he waits for me at the bottom of barrack
hill he wants to know why i'm dancing
that everyone knows dancing is a [ __ ]
thing and i wind up like cyril bensing
wearing a kilt and medals and dancing
all over with girls he says next thing
i'll be sitting in the kitchen knitting
socks
he says dancing will destroy him and i
won't be fit to play any kind of
football soccer rugby or gaelic football
itself because the dancing teaches you
to run like a [ __ ] and everyone will
laugh
i tell you i'm finished with the dancing
that i have sixpence in my pocket for
mrs o'connor's that's supposed to go
into the black boy's mouth that i'm
going to the lyric cinema instead six
minutes will get the two of us in with
toppings left over two squares of
cleaves toffee and billy and i have a
great time looking at the riders of the
purple sage
dad is sitting by the fire with ma'am
and they want to know what steps i
learned today and what they're called i
already i already did the siege of
venice in the walls of limerick which
are real dancers now i have to make up
names and dances ma'am says she never
heard of a dance called the siege of
dingle
but if that's what i learned go ahead
dance it and i dance around the kitchen
with my hands down by my sides making my
own music diddly i do today i had to do
that i died and ma'am clapping in towing
with my feet dad says ah that's a fine
dancing and you'll be a powerful irish
dancer and a credit to the men who died
for their country ma'am says that wasn't
worth much for sixpence
next week it's a george wrap film and
the week after that a cowboy film with
george o'brien then it's james cagney
and i can't take billy because i want to
get a barrett chuck to go with my cleves
toffee and i'm having a great time until
there's a terrible pain in my jaw and
it's a tooth out of my gum stuck in my
toffee and the pain is killing me still
i can't waste the toffee so i put out
the tooth and put it in my pocket and
chew the toffee on the other side of my
mouth blood and all
this pain on one side and the delicious
toffee on the other and i remember what
my uncle pack eating would say there are
times when you wouldn't know whether the
[ __ ] to go blind
i have to go home now and worry because
you can't go through the world's shorter
tooth without your mother knowing
mothers know everything and she she
always she's always looking into our
mouths to see if there's any class of a
disease there she's there by the fire
and dad is there and they're asking me
the same old questions the dance and the
name of the dance i tell them i learned
the walls of cork
and i dance around the kitchen trying to
hum a made-up tune and dying with the
pain in my tooth ma'am says walt's a
[ __ ] my eye there's no such dents and
dad says come over here
stand there before me tell us the truth
did you go to your dancing classes today
can't tell a lie anymore because my gum
is killing me and there's blood in my
mouth besides i i know they know
everything and that's what they're
telling me now some snake of a boy from
the dancing school saw me going to the
lyric cinema and told and mrs o'connor
sent the note to say she hadn't seen me
in ages and was i all right because i
had great promise and could follow in
the footsteps of the great cyril benson
dad doesn't care about my tooth or
anything he says i'm going to confession
and drags me over to the redemptorist
church because it's saturday and
confessions go on all day he tells me
i'm a bad boy he's ashamed of me that i
went to the pictures instead of learning
islands national dances the jig the real
the dances that men and women fought and
died for down these sad centuries
he says there's many a young man that
was hanged and now muldering in a lime
pit that would be glad to rise up and
dance the irish dance
the priest is old and i have to yell my
sins at him
and he tells me i'm a hooligan for going
to the pictures instead of my dancing
lessons although he thinks himself that
dancing is a dangerous thing almost as
bad as the films the stars are thought
thoughts sinful in themselves but even
if dancing is an abomination i sin by
taking my mother's sixpence and lying
there's a hot place in hell for the
likes of me
say a decker of the rosie and ask god's
forgiveness for your dancing at the
gates of hell itself child
end of my dancing career
school
between the church and the school
we suffered
greatly
and this is just this is a glimpse at
the kind of teaching
that was afforded us in leamy's national
school at this time
uh years later i became a teacher in new
york city in high school
and
since i left school when i was 13 in
ireland i went to get it
for a job as a messenger boy
and didn't go
i never went to secondary school high
school and then came to new york and
got all kinds of menial jobs and i guess
i'd still be in a menial job worried now
for the chinese
because uh the korean war broke out and
the
multi-tongue sent his army across the
yalu river into korea and i want to take
this opportunity to thank multi-tongue
for liberating me from the menial job
that i had in new york so the army got
worried i mean the united states got
worried about the koreans and the
chinese and they turned to me
and they drafted me they drafted me and
they knew i was too good to be wasted in
korea so they sent me to germany to
train dogs for two years
well i trained dogs all right but i
developed also a
a great fondness for the beers of
germany so i had a great time in germany
when i got out and i i didn't know what
to do with myself so i was walking
i was having a few beers in the white
horse bar down in the village and i got
fed up there i said this is what i'm
going to do for the rest of my life work
at these menial jobs and so on so i
walked across washington square and
there was nyu
i i applied
and they laughed hysterically at the
idea of me
going in there without a high school
diploma or any kind of high school but
they let me in on probation
for a year
providing i maintain the b average which
i did after this kind of education that
i got in limerick it was easy to
maintain a b average at nyu
then i i i got a teaching job when i
graduate and that's another story
mr o'neill is the master in the fourth
class of school we call him dottie
because he's small like a dot
he teaches in the one classroom with the
platform so that he can stand above us
and threaten us with his ash plant and
peel his apple for all to see the first
day of school in september he writes on
the blackboard three words which are to
stay there the rest of the year euclid
geometry idiom
he says if he catches any boy
interfering with these words that boy
will go through the rest of his life
with one hand
he says anyone who doesn't understand
the theorems of euclid is an idiot
now repeat after me
anyone who doesn't understand the
theorems of euclid is an idiot of course
we all know what an idiot is because
that's what the masters keep telling us
we are
brendan quigley raises his hand sir
what's a theorem a what's a euclid
we expect dottie to lash at brendan the
way all the masters do when you ask them
a question but he looks at brendan with
a little smile
i know here's a boy with not one but two
questions what's your name boy
brendan quiglisa
this is a boy who will go far where will
he go boys farsar
indeed and he will the boy who wants to
know something about the grace elegance
and beauty of euclid can go nowhere but
up in what direction and no other can
this boy go boys
up sir
without euclid boys mathematics would be
a poor daughtering thing without euclid
we wouldn't be able to go from here to
there without euclid the bike the
bicycle would have no wheel without
euclid saint joseph could not have been
a carpenter for carpentry's geometry and
geometry is carpentry without euclid
this very school could never have been
built
behind me paddy classy motors beckon
euclid
daddy barks at him you boy what's your
name
classy sir
ah the boy flies in one wing what's your
christian name paddy
patty what
petty sir
and what petty were you saying to
mccourt i said we should get down on our
two knees and thank god for euclid
i'm sure you did classy i see the lie
festering in your teeth what do i see
boys the lie sir
and what is the lie doing boys festering
sir
where boys where in his teeth sir
euclid boys was a greek
classy what is a greek
some class of a foreigner sir
crossy you are a halfway
now brendan surely you know where the
greek is yes sir euclid was a greek
dot he gives a little smile he tells
claus he should model himself and quigly
who knows what a greek is he draws two
lines side by side and tells us these
are parallel lines and the magical and
mysterious thing is they never never
meet
not if they were to be extended for
infinity not if they were extended to
god's shoulders and that boys is a long
way that there's a german jew who's
upsetting the whole war with his ideas
on parallel lines
we listen to dottie and wonder what all
this has to do with the state of the
world with the germans marching
everywhere and bombing everything that
stands we can't ask him ourselves but we
can get brendan quigley to do it anyone
can see brendan is the master's pet and
that means he can ask any questions he
likes after school we tell brendan he
has to ask that question tomorrow what
uses euclid and all those lines that go
on forever when the germans are bombing
everything that stands
brendan says he doesn't want to be the
master's pet he didn't ask for it and he
doesn't want to ask the question he's
afraid if he asks that question dot he
will attack him
we tell him if he doesn't ask that
question we'll attack him
next day brendan raises his hand dotty
gives him the little smile
sir what use is you could in all the
lines when the germans are bombing
everything that stands
their little smile is gone
brendan i quickly
oh boys or boys
he lays his stick on the desk and stands
on the platform with his eyes closed
what uses euclid he says what use
without euclid the messerschmitt could
never have taken to the sky
without euclid the spitfire could not
dart from cloud to cloud euclid brings
us grace and beauty and elegance
what does he bring us boys
grey sir and
elegant star and
beauty sir
euclid is complete in himself and divine
in application do you understand that
boys
we do sir
i doubted boys
i doubt it
to love euclid is to be alone in the
world
he opens his eyes and sighs
and you can see the eyes are a little
watered
do you have any questions
[Music]
about euclid
or anything
well i guess that if you have no
questions it means you've grasped the
deeper meaning of this book
because in a few years there will be
cliff notes
monarch notes barnes noble study guide
i'm writing it myself
complete with multiple choice questions
fill in the blank spaces matching
questions and short essay questions
unless you answer the book i'm really
curious why your parents came from
ireland went to new york and then
went back to ireland well they came
separately
he came from the north and she came from
the south and they met in new york and i
think i think they met around
thanksgiving i'm not sure
they were married in march
i was born in august
i was conceived as they say beyond the
sheets
and what the irish called a knee
trembler
that they act
performed against a wall
so um
they had me the next year they have my
brother maliki the following year they
had twins
the following year they had a little
girl which my mother had
how many
six
uh six children of five and a half years
was that possible six children of five
and a half
five children in five and a half years
since she had twins so the little girl
died in brooklyn and then she we she had
a nervous breakdown my father was my he
was probably
uh
upset by how upset is hardly the world
uh
ravaged by this so they went back to
ireland they left a depression america
and went to ireland
now an american depression is a fairly
joyful thing
compared with the depression the island
a depression in ireland is like living
in calcutta with rain
that's what they went back to and um
there was no there were no jobs there
was nothing nothing when i say nothing
nothing
there were no jobs my father couldn't
get a job because he was we were in
limerick and he had a northern accent
now it's hard for you to be it would be
like a man from new hampshire going down
to alabama in 1925
he'd be run out of town
so he it was even when he did get a job
they always look for for excuses to fire
him
so uh we we dreamed anyway maliki and i
especially since we were born here of
going back to america
which we did
and that's
that's part of the story here
michael
plans
oh mike well here my uh she had um
maliki uh me maliki
the twins margaret and then
uh
michael the father
in in limerick yeah and then alfie was
the last one alfie was uh
10 years younger than me and he's a he
was the only one that had any kind of a
chance in ireland he's the only one who
went to secondary school and we had
great hopes for him he went to secondary
school the christian brothers he came
over here
and he was in the army here and then he
got he had the gi bill too and we
thought he went to colombia and
everything and we thought he had great
hope so he gave it all up and up and mix
opened up a mexican restaurant
the only irishman you've ever heard of
what number is strange character
uh it's south of munich in a place
called land greece
dog training country
ocon
uh well it's there are lots of stories
about kohaman except he was my
i i
the way american kids grabbed uh grab
onto superman i grabbed onto coholin he
was the irish mythic hero irish achilles
if you want to call him and he was a
tragic
and i was uh
any time i went to dublin i went to the
general post office in dublin there's a
statue of cobol in there it's about
this is about the size of the podium and
he i like the way he died we we
irish love things about death
it's our one of our great pastimes
dying we uh for instance when when i was
a kid people were dying of tb all over
the place consumption or galloping
consumption
so uh whenever there was a funeral we
would go to it with nothing else to do
we'd go around the neighborhood gangs of
orchards you know the way you see kids
wandering the street and they're always
up to something well we were always up
to something looking for something to do
and we were eight or nine years old and
we would see a house with a a wreath on
the door
and a card a purple bordered mourning
card announcing that this the demise of
the whoever in the house so there was
also a tradition in ireland when
somebody died
uh the prayers of little children were
very were would get him would get them
into heaven so we knock on the door and
you couldn't turn away little shoulder
we like come and say prayer mrs
oh yeah come in the window yeah come
here
come here don't we going to kneel by the
bed and caught there we're not fueling
your homes and the body was there it
might be there for three or four days
because they couldn't bear to get rid of
it and so and it's sometimes quite
rancid quite juicy and they have incense
and candles and flowers and everything
so we
i remember one time one of our
schoolmates died clement or handler was
his name he died of tb and and usually
people became emaciated but clemens
swelled up he swallowed up and then he
shrunk again so there's clement in the
bed when i was then uh mrs o'hara said
poor clement his little friends come in
and pray for him
so uh
i i got this all for free and the
clement looked exactly like a monkey
and i wanted to laugh
but you can't laugh at a dead boy
so she's then she says
kiss him
to me
that's no it's all right mrs henley
kiss him so she lifts me up and she
pushes me at him
and i'll i i'll never forget
the smell of clement or hendon he was a
nice kid but not when he was dead
so we went to all these funerals we went
and we go we got the graveyard to see
them buried and maliki and i went to so
many fuelians we belong to the death of
the month club
that's it
yeah
why now
i didn't write it earlier
i i don't think i would have had the
distance
that i have now now that i'm older and
less wise
uh
i i think i would have
i might have had a chip on my shoulder i
might have had scores to settle and so
on but i had to get over that tried to
give it and not impose that on the
reader
it's an imposition
you were in other words
oh
yeah i was everything before it was
fashionable
27 years
and
one of my students here she just
introduced me
and i meet them everywhere i think i had
estimated that in my career i had 10 000
students
public oh yeah that's where i learned
anything i know
they taught me what was the music that
you did with your brother and
is there a couple of laggards
when did you do that we started in 1984
and we did it around the country we went
to chicago for three weeks and stayed
for a year
we went to chicago san francisco for
three weeks and stayed for five months
so we've been doing it on and off but
i'm finished with that
one
one yeah it's not really a musical it's
a storyteller
uh uh well i i told my editor in new
york she asked she asked me when this
book would be finished
this was la uh july of 1985 in 1995. and
i plucked a date over there i said i'll
i'll bring it to you on
the birthday of my favorite writer
jonathan swift the 30th of november and
i delivered it on the third and she was
shocked
if you're not supposed to do that so i'm
planning
the birthday of james joyce no
february 2nd 1998.
did you ever hear anything from your dad
again
i saw him once
in his coffin
in belfast
i i went to his funeral i don't know why
i just felt
well you do things sometimes because in
the back of your head you're going to
write a book
did you ever find that blonde
you always dreamed about walking down
the street i did unfortunately
married one of them
[Applause]
like to thank you we're going to ask you
to line up going back this way with your
books the books are for sale at the cash
register right behind you if you'd like
to pick one up
and uh mr mccourt will be personalizing
this evening so we'll come around and
ask you what you'd like written down
thank you for coming
yeah you're passing books over here
um
to dinah
on her 79th birthday
and something about belfast my mother
was born and raised in belfast this is
my mother
this man doesn't know anything about
belfast dad was
two of them were visiting me recently
and uh i got i've been there a number of
times in the last couple of years good i
was there last year well things are not
so good there right now i was there at
christmas it was lovely then
talks broke down
oh about that thanks
um
[Music]
thanks
thank you thank you
hi
so you're from new york no i'm i'm the
salesman here in the midwest for simon
she's doing school oh lucky
well i think pretty lucky
he truly is
to frank frank to frank one liger to
another
thank you
this is from
colorado
i was having a big conversation with my
neighbor next door who comes from
from court actually
and she said you know i just
i never she read the review in the post
dispatch she said i don't think that
existed before i think well
it existed
the review you have to be able to see
what what sunday's paper um three weeks
ago
if you could just your name would be
funny
so if it wasn't this past songs
to anyone in particular
oh you could if you decided to date it
that would be great thank you very much
it was a really
good presentation
years of training
yes book signing school you like working
your fingers out a little bit yeah
you just have to trust me that it makes
sense
in a minute retired judge leon
higginbotham talks about his new book
shades of freedom racial politics and
presumptions of the american legal
process
about books airs saturdays at 8 pm
eastern end pacific times and sundays at
9